so Skyrim NPCs have at times hilarious
dialogue what does it take to build a
good NPC dialogue
the main thing is to make them reactive
a lot of times when you write characters
for movies or things like that you want
to make that character
interesting for themselves right what's
their story
and there's some characters like that
that the player definitely cares about
but the best characters are the ones
that react to you so you'll find a lot
of people love our guards
and the guards are written almost purely
to be reactive
hey nice tie like your jacket do this
cool watch you know hey what'd you do
and so that hey you're the man
as you walk by
that makes them interesting or the way
they react to something that you do
Lydia in Skyrim who everybody loves I'm
sworn to carry your burdens that's a
generic line
that all of the you know house Carls
have
and it just kind of lands when she says
it
why does it land what do you what do you
do and did you anticipate with land
there's a slight snarkiness in that
particular read of it and you're asking
her to do something and
she's reacting to you
what about the
the trade-off between
maybe the randomness and the scripted
nature of the dialogue like is there any
room for randomness of the dialogue tree
oh absolutely we tend to write them in
Stacks with you know it's a it's a very
small I think it was a small state
machine that just says okay
this is what's happening here's a random
list of things I could say to that
and then some of that
um plays out in ways you don't
anticipate but we look at the things
what are the players doing that we could
have the characters respond to that they
don't expect you know jumping on tables
or stealing stuff or
um
you know sneaking in in the middle of
the night or those kind of things the
more that we can do the more reactive
and interesting the characters
up here
and
these State machines how big are these
things are these individual to the
individual characters that's just
fascinating how you design State
machines is it just just a giant I would
think of the AI as one big one
oh so for sort of everybody
so there's an AI
there's a manager for all the people and
one of the things people manager right
nice one of the things that makes what
we do particularly unique
is
and this is a trade-off for what people
are seeing because a lot of it's not on
the screen but we're using Cycles to run
this which is we're thinking about
everybody in the whole world all the
time
the ones that are further away at a much
less tick rate they go until low but we
know if they want to walk across the
world and we're running every Quest
at the same time whereas in other wealth
World Games you start an activity the
rest of the world is going to shut down
so that they can really make that as
impactful
we're I I really prefer that the rest of
it's going on it's more of a simulation
that we're building
so when those things Collide that's
where it gets the most interesting
and so we're running all of those people
and understanding where they want to go
and their cycles and what they want to
do and the ones that are closer to you
we just update a lot more it's one way
to think about it
I mean that's really fascinating that's
something that people had uh
they were wondering about to what degree
is possible to run the world without you
so there is a feeling to role-playing
games that you're the central you're the
center of the world the whole world
rotates around you as it does in normal
life like when we walk around there's a
when you forget yourself you start to
take yourself very seriously like you
are the center of the world uh you
forget that there's eight billion people
on Earth and if you gotta have lies
that's actually a sobering realization
that they all have really interesting
life stories and they have their worries
they suffer in different
complicated ways
and yet
when you play a role-playing game
there's a
I mean both computationally from a
storytelling perspective you wonder if
the world goes on without you like if
you come back if you take a break and
you come back is there still a bustling
town that now has a history since you
have last visited so to what degree can
you create a world that goes on without
you or goes on at the same time as you
do your thing whatever the heck you're
doing we don't prioritize the stuff you
can't see so it's more like an amusement
park if you study like the design or
level designers did this how do they
build Disney World in these places so it
still exists
for you the player
so it is fairly you know when you're
going to come in this is what you're
going to see the shops are in the front
you're going to do this
it's just for us to make it far more
believable and get some more emergent
Behavior
that not just make that sort of the
varisimilitude of what you're in for
that moment
but you you buy it all I always say like
you know we got to do the little things
so that you buy the reality of the
virtual world you're in so we want to do
something crazy you know in a dragon
lands or a death law comes out of the
Wasteland or those kind of things that
you it has the impact to you as the
viewer
that it would to the people in the world
okay
but still you are simulating stuff
that's close to you it is a bit of a
simulation going on oh absolutely yes
and so that creates some interesting
Dynamics then and the stuff that we're
looking at in the future in our plan is
to push that even more
to think about
how these things exist in the world
first
then we do some of this but even more so
in the future to say how do these things
exist take like a faction in the world
what is their role in the world as
opposed to just their role is for the
player to join it go through a bunch of
quests and become the head of the
faction
you know think a little bit deeper about
the simulation and what would the Mages
Guild be doing in a fantasy world
or the Fighter's Guild be doing in a
fantasy world versus just
sign up do quests get gold
and so that when you show up to that
Mages Guild
it's a bustling Guild full of stuff
going on it's not just that it's
bustlings that they feel rooted in it
they don't feel like a storefront for
come here do quests get experience
is that one of the essential components
of randomly generated worlds
so when I think back to Daggerfall as a
gigantic world when I first played it I
thought like
I mean you're just struck by the the the
the immensity of it right the immensity
of the possibility when you're young and
you look into your future it's it's wide
open and you can do anything and that's
what Daggerfall felt like the openness
was gigantic
and Daggerfall is interesting coming off
Arena where Arena does the same thing
but Daggerfall in many ways is bigger
despite focusing on an area because of
how the density of okay this is how this
is how much physical game Space will do
for these Villages and towns and it does
feel endless even though you're looking
at a map that has constraints
and Daggerfall actually was a touchstone
for us going into Starfield
for how we do the planets
because there is
there's a different kind of gameplay
experience when you just wander outside
a city in Daggerfall
then you know follow a quest line and go
through go to this place and it's
completely handcrafted and everything
around every corner we've kind of placed
like Skyrim
you know star Field's a bit more like
Daggerfall and if you want her outside
the city
we're going to be generating things and
you kind of get used to that game Flow
different than we've done before and
fun in a different kind of way
we'll talk about Starfield so just for
people who don't know and how dare you
for not knowing but uh where with
Daggerfall we're talking about the Elder
Scrolls series that started sort of
talking about the big titles within the
series started with arena in 94
Daggerfall in 96 I didn't look up the
years before this this is depressing or
or awesome
um so all of these games
brought hundreds probably for some of
them thousands of hours of joy for me so
Arena Daggerfall Morrowind Oblivion and
Skyrim
so I don't remember arena being that
open world well it's all the provinces
it follows kind of the same pattern it
just doesn't have all the number of
villages and places that Daggerfall has
while Daggerfall focuses on the iliac
Bay
area arena does it all just changes the
scale in terms of
you know one block on the map equals
this much space there is something that
I mean I'm speaking anecdotal experience
but I just remember it feeling
wide open Daggerfall it definitely was
yeah the way Arena didn't
I don't remember maybe maybe because
Arena
it was so cool to have the just the
role-playing game aspect you're focused
on the items and the character
development you Daggerfall has a lot
more depth particularly in the character
system that's what it introduces all of
the skills and those kind of things
Arena
it's actually it's a game I love
um and it's very very elegant if you
look at the first one where it's just an
XP based system do this get XP level up
very classic role-playing game
um Daggerfall digs deep into who's your
character how are you going to develop
it what are your skills there's
advantages there's disadvantages and the
environment going full 3d
from Arena which is actually like a two
and a half D Doom style engine
um that I agree with you that Daggerfall
feels like there's more possibilities uh
when you're playing it were you able to
like look up the sky in Daggerfall yep
my memories yeah so that's what full 3d
means and then you can go outside the
city you can walk outside and says you
can do that in Arena too but it looks
more fakey right it's all going to be a
flat plane Here Comes things and then a
dungeon entrance is a you know 8-bit
here comes a little a flat coming at the
camera